hey there are you ready to understand a
song in English let's learn English with
Taylor Swift's hit new song me so if you
want to understand fast speaking names
without getting lost without missing the
jokes and without subtitles then be sure
it's hit that subscribe button and the
bell down below because we help you to
do that every single week I'm a handful
informally speaking if someone is a
handful they are very difficult to deal
with or control example role their son
is calm and responsible for the little
one is a bit of a handful a handful is
literally the amount of something that
can be held in one hand it can also
refer to a small number of people or
things example put about a handful of
chocolate chips in the cookies she
invited all of her friends to the party
but only a handful of them turned up
baby as used in the song baby is a term
of endearment that is a loving word used
for calling the people you're intimate
with in the case of the word baby it's
mostly used between two people who are
automatically involved sometimes we
reduce it to babe example why are you up
so early babe hey honey do you think we
should invite your parents for dinner as
we see later in the song one can also
say baby doll however this is less
common nowadays it would be used more to
refer to women than men I never think
before I jump here Taylor is actually
speaking metaphorically if you don't
think before you jump in this figurative
sense you act impulsively taking risks
without thinking about the consequences
learn a lot more about how to use
figurative expressions in English to
sound more native-like with this lesson
with the Jonas Brothers
[Music]
ladies chicks lady and chick are both
alternative colloquial ways to say woman
particularly a young woman keep in mind
chick is a bit more slangy than lady
example a chick over there with a
sunglasses is beautiful an equivalent of
lady for man would be guy which we also
see in this song example the ladies had
cocktails and chatted while the guys
were watching a football game went
psycho on the phone the word psycho is a
term for someone who is mentally
unstable now while it can be used in a
more serious context when referring to
people who are actually affected by
mental disease it is also used as slang
to refer to moments when one acts very
irrational like a crazy person to go
psycho on the phone is to act in such a
way while speaking on the phone example
his little sister went psycho when he
stole our candy pronunciation though the
pee and psycho is completely silent
psycho hey do you want to understand
fast speaking natives well we want to
help you out we teach you exactly how in
our free three-part mini course you can
learn more about that and sign up by
clicking up here or down in the
description below
[Music]
never leave well enough alone if
something is well enough it means that
it is satisfactory example I left her
well enough but I wasn't convinced to
ask her out on a date if you never leave
well enough alone it means you are not
content with something being
satisfactory in other words you want
things to be exceptional or even perfect
Taylor probably means that she can't be
happy that her relationship is going
well she wants it to be more exciting
you'll never find another like me you'll
never find another like me
[Music]
I'm the only one of me this is another
way to say I'm completely unique another
similar and more common expression is
one of a kind we can use it to describe
both people and things example Emilia
Clarke is one of a kind she's beautiful
and a terrific actress this model of the
Audi r8 is one of kind they haven't made
any others like it that's the fun of me
the aspect of something that makes it
entertaining so she is saying that what
makes her amusing as a person is the
fact that she is unique example I don't
like monopoly there's too much strategy
involved what that's the fun of it it's
summed up by these two lines the message
of the song is probably that each of our
uniqueness is what makes us fun great
and special
[Music]
to make it about somebody to connect
something that happened to a specific
person even though they might not be
related or at fault if you make it about
yourself as Brendan does here it means
that you are taking something personally
whether or not it is actually related to
you example stop trying to make it about
you my decision has nothing to do with
you
she makes everything about her she
doesn't even think about anyone else
tend to to have the tendency to to be
likely though not definite to behave in
a particular way or have a particular
characteristic example we tend to get
cold winters and warm dry summers in
this part of the country
British people traditionally tend to not
display much emotion in public
I know you never get just what you see
tube or somebody to talk or act in a way
that makes somebody else lose interest
in what you are saying or doing this
verb is more commonly heard in the form
of expressions such as tube or somebody
out of their mind
or for somebody to tears which is more
emphatic but means the same as just tube
or example I'm not going to bore you
with all the details the movie bored me
to tears
do you love Taylor Swift we've actually
done a couple lessons with her music and
an interview you can find all those in
this new playlist by clicking up here or
down in the description below lame the
opposite of cool boring not trendy or
fashionable example those shoes are
laying our new English teacher is always
making lame jokes walk away phrasal verb
meaning literally to walk in the
opposite direction of something or
figuratively as in the song to leave or
abandon someone example as we were
walking away from the beach I found a
twenty dollar bill in the sand you
should never just walk away from a fight
[Music]
keep you company to a company or spend
time with someone in order to prevent
them from feeling lonely or bored
example do you give me company for a
while I don't want to be alone
[Music]
but you know
there ain't no I in team but you know
there is a me the expression there is no
I in team is common in sports or the
workplace to say that when you are
participating in a group effort you
can't be selfish or only think about
yourself it does this by saying that the
letter I which is also the first person
subject pronoun is not found in the
spelling of team the song then
contradicts this common expression by
saying that although team does not have
the letter I it does have the letters M
and E which can make the first person
object pronoun me learn more about this
expression and other common sports
idioms in this lesson with friends
strike the band up a band is a group
that plays music to animate a crowd for
example at a sporting event this phrasal
verb is a specific jargon in this
context to strike the band up means to
make the band start playing a piece of
music a more common use of strike up
means to start a casual conversation
example I struck up a conversation with
a barista at the cafe alright I hope
you've had a lot of fun learning with
the song remember if you want to
maximize your fluency to listen to it
again and again to really remember all
that new vocabulary and improve your
pronunciation by singing along now if
you want to support our Channel and let
YouTube know that you want more videos
like this then be sure to hit that like
button below and remember to also
subscribe also check out that free
three-part mini course I told you about
check out this playlist with all of our
lessons teaching you English with songs
and this other lesson I think you'll
really enjoy and now it's time to go
beyond the classroom and live your
English oh yeah